se nos pide trazar estos números en la
recta numérica y como puedes notar cada
uno de ellos tiene un cada uno de estos
números tiene un signo de valor absoluto
entonces hagamos un repaso de lo que es
un valor absoluto un valor absoluto hay
dos maneras de pensar en él a la primera
sería qué distancia tiene un número al
cero entonces ubicar a este menos tres
en la recta numérica dibuja una recta
numérica primero lo que voy a hacer es
poner los números en la recta numérica y
después después calcular el valor
absoluto de cada uno de esos números
entonces aquí ya tenemos tenemos al
menos tres bueno primero el primero
primero el cero entonces el cero después
ya tenemos aquí el menos uno el menos
dos y el menos 3
entonces ahí está el -3 en el valor
absoluto de menos 3 o de cualquier
número no se está esencialmente diciendo
qué tan lejos estás del origen que tan
lejos estás del 0 que qué distancia hay
del -3 al 0
veamos 1 233 unidades entonces tenemos
que el valor absoluto de menos 3 es
igual a 3 positivo ahora bien esa es la
manera conceptual de ver el valor
absoluto qué tan lejos estás del cero
pero hay una manera más sencilla para
calcular el valor absoluto y consiste
consiste simplemente en ver el número
observas ese número si es positivo o
negativo no importa el resultado siempre
será positivo siempre será la versión
positiva de ese número aquí el valor
absoluto de menos 3 es igual a 3
positivos
el valor absoluto de 3 positivo también
es 3 positivo así que siempre obtendrás
la versión positiva del número y aquí
tenemos todos estos todos estos son
valores absolutos todos serán valores
positivos serán mayores que 0 entonces
voy a dibujar mi recta numérica creo que
la puedo hacer mejor que eso
y allí está una mejor una mejor cita sí
sí éste es cero
aquí tenemos menos uno tenemos uno dos
tres cuatro cinco seis y siete creo que
con eso está bien entonces esta primera
cantidad valor absoluto de menos tres lo
acabamos de hacer eso es 3 positivo
entonces se ubica justo aquí y seguimos
con el valor absoluto de 7 el valor
absoluto de 7 tenemos aquí
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 7 a qué distancia está el
7 del 0 está justamente a 7 unidades
entonces el valor absoluto de 7 es igual
a 7 y aquí tal vez ya puedes ver el
patrón si es negativo se hace positivo y
si es positivo se queda igual entonces 7
7 está aquí y el valor absoluto de 7 es
igual a 7 el valor absoluto de menos 3
es igual a 3 positivo esto esto voy a
marcarlo
esto de aquí es el 0 y el 0 y acá está
el 0 porque estamos estamos viendo la
relación que hay en distancia cero así
que ahora vamos con el valor absoluto de
8 menos 12 8 menos 12 que es si le
quitamos 12 al 8 eso eso es menos 4 12
menos que 8 es igual a menos 4 de hecho
lo puedes hacer lo puedes hacer en la
recta numérica pero pon atención porque
porque si le quitamos piénsalo si le
quitamos 8 al 8 eso nos da 0 después
vamos retrocediendo otros 4 entonces
sería menos 1 - 2 - 3 hasta llegar al
menos 4 por lo tanto esto es igual al
valor absoluto de menos 4 el menos 4
está acá está menos 1 - 2 - 3 y menos 4
pero estamos tomando su valor absoluto
qué distancia hay del menos 4 al 0 está
a cuatro unidades del cero está aquí a
1234 por lo tanto esto es igual a 4 lo
pongo acá
entonces el valor absoluto de 8 menos 12
es igual al valor absoluto de menos 4 lo
cual es igual a 4 positivo luego mi
favorito vamos con el valor absoluto del
0 ajá ese es divertido qué distancia hay
del 0 al 0 que distancia hay del 0 al 0
0 no no hay distancia no hay distancia
no se mueve por lo tanto el valor
absoluto de 0 es igual a 0
ajá y ahora por último vamos con el
valor absoluto de 7 menos 2 el valor
absoluto de 7 menos 27 menos 2 es igual
a 5 entonces esto es igual al valor
absoluto de 5
y por lo tanto bueno qué distancia hay
del 5 al 05 unidades
es muy fácil es demasiado fácil tenemos
aquí 1 2 3 4 5 baja entonces estas cinco
unidades del 0 por lo tanto el valor
absoluto de 5 es igual a 5 y entonces
conceptualmente es la distancia que hay
del 0 y pero en términos simples si un
número es negativo se hace positivo si
ese número es positivo se queda positivo
cuando toma su valor absoluto